okay well there's been a lot of
discussion here about the Middle East I
was on the panel on the balance of power
in the Middle East yesterday because one
of the world's most intractable problems
is the the conflict between Israelis and
Palestinians that went on for such a
long time so there is a lot of
discussion here about what to do about
that we've had the Palestinian Prime
Minister mr. Fayyad here also the Prime
Minister Jordan the king of Jordan is is
coming here and we are really looking in
the coming here for some new impetus
behind the Middle East peace process
President Obama really put some effort
behind that in 2009 it hasn't bought a
lot of fruit yes so we really need and
an incoming British government whoever
wins the general election in a few
months time also needs to put some new
momentum behind that process so it's not
so much that there are new ideas here
there aren't really any new ideas in
Middle East peace matters it's how to
get agreement on Israelis and
Palestinians discussing things properly
together again